my record is not great on the woke
commercials
where i try to guess what product the
commercials
are trying to sell beyond radical
leftism i'm i'm man enough to admit
my record not terrific we've lost count
thankfully i think the producers lost
count to let me keep some of my dignity
but we have more i've gotten better at
this i am going to hone in with
all my expert skill in this pc woke
culture
to tell you what these companies are
selling before we get started this
video is sponsored by home title lock
leader in home title protection
more from them later first let's roll
the tape
the prototype that we've built are they
sorry are they
always apologizing not my experience
sorry
do you have a minute
i'm sorry i hate it when men sit
sorry it should just work
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
don't be sorry
oh it's it's a shampoo yeah that
i have a question why don't we go back
to the original thing oh i thought that
was the end of the commercial like be
strong and shine pantene or something
i'm gonna say it's shampoo okay the
shine is giving me
[Music]
yeah nailed it oh kid that's so good i
it was there was only one word in there
that could pass i guess two words maybe
the strong you want strong hair
but it was really only shine that tipped
me off to it
and i knew if it was going to be anyone
was going to be pantene they have a
commercial out
now that basically commits child abuse
in the commercial it's so woke
that that's really great and also
because
all of tv is just made for women
i'm not there's no that's not even a
joke it's just that is actually what tv
is written for because women see these
commercials and buy these products
all right that in a thousand today keep
rolling growing up i was always trying
to figure out what kind of man i wanted
to become and i'm still
trying to figure out what kind of man
that i want to become samson that's good
different i didn't know that there was a
term
for the type of person that i was i went
into my transition
just wanting to be happy i'm glad i i'm
at the point where i'm able to shave
south south is it like gillette or
something i think they're the ones that
just
west never in a hurry
right
now don't be scared i'm scared
yeah i i actually remember this
commercial at the time
you are doing fine i'm at the point in
my manhood where
i'm actually happy it's not just myself
transitioning it's everybody around me
transitioning
that's a that's actually a brilliant
[Music]
line
gillette the best a man can get yeah so
harry's racers the best a man can get
so bat in a thousand that's great that
line is actually pretty insightful
though it's not me who's
transitioning it's not me who's changing
it's everyone around me is changing
because that
that is the demand i mean first of all
the premise here is
that it's really good and right and just
and compassionate
to tell little girls that they have to
pump themselves full of hormones and do
other sort of
mutilations to their body to be to
become more similar in appearance to
little boys that somehow that's really
great
and then there's the claim here that you
know now
this woman is much happier which
the statistics don't exactly bear this
out i'm not sure that
happiness however you measure it would
justify it anyway but
you know you have anecdotes here but the
statistics in terms of suicidality
anxiety depression after
the gender reassignment surgery just
does not show a statistically
significant change at all
but then that point that line in there
is really good it's everyone else who's
changing because in order to
indulge this gender ideology we all have
to
lie a very bad commercial because like
we i don't think we should be forcing
little girls to start shaving
or indulging people in in those sorts of
delusions but
a fairly insightful ad too oh no my home
got
stolen i am holding a copy right here of
the legal title
to my home and here is my signature that
says that i sold my home
only i didn't now i
am happy to say i was just fooling you
this is not the legal title to my home
okay i was good i was gonna hold it up
but i figured some of you derelicts out
there might actually steal it so that
would not be good
if this were the legal title however i
would have just lost my home
to identity thieves this actually
happens i
didn't realize that this is such a a
real problem
but cyber criminals are getting so
sophisticated so what happens is the
title documents to our homes
are kept online the thief forges your
signature on a quit claim deed
stating that you sold your home and he's
the new owner
then he takes out loans using your
home's equity
and leaves you in debt and you won't
know about that until late payment or
even eviction notices arrive
that is why i strongly suggest home
title
lock the instant home title lock detects
someone tampering
with your home's title they will help to
shut it down
let's get you protected go to
hometitlelock.com register your address
to see if you are already a victim and
enter knowles canon wles
for 30 free days of protection that is
promo code knowles at hometitlelock.com
let's get back to the videos
so obviously it's another another gender
[Music]
video
[Music]
gemma gemma miller
hey dad hey carol you remember my gemma
[Music]
and what's your name it's james
[Music]
starbucks james
[Music]
so you know
the the reason that i really believe
this ad
is because at starbucks it is a
requirement to spell people's names
wrong
so i have no doubt that starbucks you go
i said my name is gemma so james sounded
like james to me sorry
that is not surprising at all that i
don't know if i get credit for that
because you know
you he she she i guess
was buying starbucks at the very end or
was buying coffee and i assumed it was
starbucks because
starbucks is super woke so i'm going to
take that one i'm going to take that
to bring back my average absolutely not
three for three
these are also really insightful
truth-telling advertisements
this time that's the end this is the
first time ever
that i have batted a thousand on this i
think it's it's because
these commercials were so
unintentionally
insightful they gave away all these
clues head on over
and make sure that you post whatever
other videos you want us to review
you can tweet them at me you can post
them in the comments it's probably the
easiest
you can email them to me but but send
them on over especially now that i'm
getting a little bit better we're gonna
we're gonna get that we're gonna get
that average back
up everybody before we're just all
completely d platform because we're not
allowed to state any of the things that
we think
see you next time
you